saint valentin céleste patron des
amoureux est également le nom d'un petit
village de l'âme et hier ils étaient 95
couple de fiancés à venir à saint
valentin au pèlerinage désormais
traditionnel d amour dès l'aube le petit
village était envahie et même le soleil
n'avait pas voulu manquer cette fête de
l'amitié et des gens qui sait
les amoureux étaient tout d'abord fleuri
les jeunes filles recevaient un bouquet
la fiancée de moutonnière un badge
portant en lettres d'argent sur fond
bleu le nom de leur vie
précédait déviait les cornemuses de la
rabouilleuse et des gars du berry main
dans la main les jeunes gens saouls
dirigé vers l'église de l'apparence
devant l'hôtel florida hier aux les
amoureux étaient bénis par le révérend
père cadeau saint valentin était ensuite
porté par quatre fiancées qui prenait la
tête d'un cortège pour gagner issoudun
ainsi dans ce petit village de l'indre
le seul à porter le nom de saint
valentin 95 couple heureux ont honoré
leur saint patron
et c'est sur ce baiser symbole de cette
journée que nous leur souhaiterons
beaucoup de bonheur